hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve
minimum cost to connect all points and
surprise this actually is not a problem
from the blind 75 list that we've been
working on recently
and the reason i'm solving this problem
is because honestly it actually
should be a part of that list like this
is one of those problems i think that's
missing from the blind 75 list reason
being
is this is a problem related to minimum
spanning trees a concept that a lot of
people skip over i think when they
grind leak code so this is what we're
going to be doing today and you might
have heard of an algorithm for minimum
spanning trees there's actually a couple
prims algorithm and there's also crust
goals
we're going to be doing prims algorithm
because i think it's easier to implement
and it's actually more efficient most of
the time
and you might remember this algorithm
from college most
most computer science curriculums do
teach it but if you're anything like me
you probably forgot it the instant
that you you know finished the class
that you learned it in
but that's okay and this algorithm
prim's algorithm is actually not as
complicated as you might expect
so we're just given a list of points
that represent some coordinates on a 2d
plane so
we're for each point we're given two
values the x-coordinate and the
y-coordinate so the cost of connecting
any two particular points like let's say
these two points circled
down there the cost of connecting them
is just going to be the absolute value
of the
x difference plus the absolute value of
the y difference so it's actually not
you know the the cost of connecting them
is not going to be like the diagonal
it's going to be the
x distance and the y distance in other
words the manhattan distance if you've
heard of that term
that's pretty easy to calculate good for
us and for the entire
set of points in this case we're given
five points we want to know what's the
minimum
possible cost to connect all points
and they also say that any pair of
points is going to be connected by
exactly one
simple path i think that's that
information is actually redundant just
saying that we want the minimum cost to
connect all points
pretty much tells you this is going to
be a minimum spanning tree problem
so the only question is where the heck
are the edges for this graph we're only
given
points right so but they do tell us
pretty much what an edge is going to be
right with the cost
of each uh connection is just going to
be the distance so we have to create our
edges
ourselves so basically all possible
edges could be you know every single
point
to connect it to every other point right
that's going to be a set of edges and we
can continue that so for example you
know this point to connect
all the other uh points as well so we're
gonna have to kind of manually create
the points
so for each pair of points in the entire
graph we're just gonna take the
manhattan distance between them and just
call that an
edge and then you know have our list of
edges or basically we're going to create
an adjacency list
so that is kind of like the pre-work we
have to do that's step one
in this problem creating the edges but
as soon as you create the edges
this is literally just a problem that
you can go ahead and take
prim's algorithm and just apply the
textbook definition of prim's algorithm
to this problem and you will get the
optimal solution and the time complexity
of that is going to be n squared log n
because n squared is going to be the
number of edges we're going to have
right because
to connect each pair of points we could
potentially have n squared edges where n
is the number of points that we're given
and login
is going to come from prem's algorithm
because we're going to be using
a min heap in this problem so it's
pretty similar in a way to jigstra's
algorithm
digixtra's minimum path algorithm
if you if you are familiar with that
prim's algorithm is pretty similar to
that so let's
jump into it so prim's algorithm is an
algorithm to find minimum spanning trees
so there's a few concepts you have to be
familiar with to understand prim's
algorithm to obviously
you need prim's algorithm to solve this
problem efficiently so i'm just gonna
give some of the background in case you
don't know it
so basically let's say you have a graph
and in this case
we have a graph with five nodes or
vertices right
and to connect all of these nodes
together
without forming a cycle so we want
every node to be connected together but
we don't want to form a cycle how many
edges is it going to take us to
accomplish that it's going to take
exactly n minus 1 edges so if we have
five nodes it's going to take exactly
four edges to connect all of them
together
without creating a cycle because take a
look right now i have four edges
right if i add another edge that's not a
duplicate if i add an edge here we
create
a cycle if i add an edge here we create
a cycle right
that's just kind of something you know
and i think it intuitively does make
sense
because you know if you start out with
five nodes you add one edge
now we have four different you know
connected components we have one here
one here and then a couple here every
time you add an edge you're decreasing
the total number of connected components
by one
so if we start out with five nodes we
add four edges we de
we decrease the number of connected
components by four then we're going to
be left with one connected component so
if we add another edge on top of that
we're going to get a cycle
so we want to connect all of these
without creating a cycle because that's
what a minimum spanning tree is
so our goal is to connect all of these
with
exactly four edges but prim's algorithm
or
the definition of a minimum spanning
tree is also
one more condition we want to minimize
the total
cost of the edges now i didn't actually
draw all of the edges all the possible
edges out right now it would look
something like this right basically for
every single node
it could possibly be connected to every
other single node and the reason i'm not
drawing it is as you can see
it's going to get really complicated
really quickly
so this is pretty much what it would
look like if i drew every possible edge
that could exist
in this graph and i think that's going
to make it a little bit too messy but
let's just assume
that those edges do exist that for any
point we could possibly connect it
to another point so the way prim's
algorithm works is we can choose to
start at
any single node in the entire graph
and then very simple we're just gonna
perform
a bfs a breath first search on
that node where we are gonna
continuously be
for every node that we're adding we're
gonna have two data structures we're
gonna have a
visit data structure to to make sure
that we don't add
the same node twice because if we add
the same node twice
that's how you know we're gonna get a
cycle we want to avoid
cycles the second data structure we're
gonna use is a minimum heat
which is gonna keep track of our
frontier
of our breadth first search now what is
a frontier
well you might know that let's say we
had a single node
so we visited this this is in our graph
right this is part of our
minimum spanning tree what's the
frontier then basically every possible
node
that could be added from this position
right so
initially if we just had one node these
four nodes
would be in our frontier but we're not
just gonna have
each node in the front here so we're
gonna have you know let's say
node one and we're also gonna add the
weight of connecting node one so let's
say the weight of the edge was something
like five
then we'd add one five in our min heap
but we're not going to add it in this
order we're gonna add it in the opposite
order
five one because when we're popping from
the min heap
we're gonna be wanting to pop whatever
node we can connect
next with the minimum possible cost
so let's say we had five you know three
two and you know up here we have a six
or something
out of all these four nodes which of
them can we connect with the minimum
possible cost that's what we're going to
use our min heap for
looking at it you can tell okay this one
because it has a cost of
2 so then we're going to connect that
that so then that's going to be a part
of our frontier
so next we're going to say okay we have
two nodes
a part of our frontier next what we're
gonna do is add
more nodes to our frontier even though
we already had
all three of these nodes we're gonna add
them again
to our frontier because now possibly if
we're if we're starting from node four
and we're trying to connect to three
one or two it's possible that the
connection
from four to three or four to two or
four to one
could be smaller than the connection
from one
to those respective nodes so we always
want to connect a node
with the minimum possible cost that it
takes us if it costs
less to connect it to four then to
connect it to one
we're going to take the one with the
smaller cost and of course
as we visit nodes we visit zero we visit
four we're gonna add them to our hash
set so
that we don't you know starting from
four we're not gonna go back to one and
add one
again because that would create a loop
and how do you know that we can
stop the execution of prim's algorithm
well once the
length of our visit set the the number
of nodes that we've added
is equal to 5 which is the number of
nodes that we started
out with so with all that being said you
just have to understand how these data
structures are contributing to the
solution and then we can go ahead and
walk through it so let's start at zero
you can start at any node you can start
at three
two four but in this case we're gonna
start at zero just because it makes
sense
so when we start at zero what we're
doing is we're adding it to visit and
we're adding it to the frontier so
what's the
cost of connecting zero well if we're
just connecting a single node to the
graph we're not actually including any
edges so the cost is going to be zero
and the node value is going to be zero
and so the way this algorithm works is
at each step we're just going to
pop from the min heap so let's pop the
first value
this right so the total cost so far is
zero right we don't actually have to add
any cost
and that's actually one other variable
we're going to be maintaining let me
just write it down down here
so so far the cost is zero we're going
to continuously be adding to it though
but next for zero we're now going to add
every one of its
neighbors to the frontier and the way
we're gonna add it i haven't drawn it
out but there is gonna be like an
adjacency list
so we will have a list of neighbors for
zero of course it could be connected to
every single point in the entire graph
that's just how this
problem is defined now i'm not going to
write the exact
cost of each of these edges because i
think it's pretty
obvious from the picture that this is
going to be the one that's closest and
the cost of connecting to that is going
to be 4 based on the
point values that we were given in the
previous picture so
out of all these four these are going to
be in our frontier
so all of these are going to be in our
frontier and you can see i drew them
here i didn't specify the actual cost
of 2 3 and 4 because i don't want to
focus too much on that because we know
that this is going to be the minimum so
this
is the one that we care about right now
because we already can tell from the
picture that it's the smallest
and so that's the step right so you take
the entire frontier add it to the min
heap
next step we're just going to repeat the
same thing that we just did we're going
to take a look at our frontier
pop the minimum from it we know that
this is the minimum so pop
it when you pop a node we have to add it
to visited so we popped the one node
right
and so we're going to add it to visit
and the cost of that one was
four right so let's just add four to our
total cost so far
and since this one was popped let me
just draw that that is definitely going
to be an
edge inside of our minimum spanning tree
so now we
are at one and now we're going to add
every adjacent node or every neighbor of
this
to our frontier as well so you can see
that that this is kind of what the graph
is going to look like
we're not going to add 1 to our frontier
because it's actually already been
visited
but we are going to add 2 3 and 4 to our
frontier now notice they already exist
in our frontier right so we're going to
be adding them
multiple times that's kind of how the n
squared is going to come from right we
could possibly add
n squared nodes to this min heap because
we're going to be adding it for every
possible
edge that exists in our graph and every
time we pop from the min heap it's going
to be
log n so basically the time complexity
is n squared multiplied
by log n so i'm not going to redraw all
three of these
nodes but you can assume that yes there
could be duplicates of them
inside of our min heap now looking at 1
which
node is the closest to it now of course
3 is the closest node
to our entire graph this is our entire
graph right we have two nodes right
what's the closest node that we can add
to this graph right we could add it
anywhere we could
say okay this is going to be connected
to zero right or three is going to be
connected to zero or three is going to
be connected to one we could add
any node but we know just by looking at
the picture that this is what's the
closest
is gonna be and i'll just tell you okay
for that node three the cost is gonna be
three so now we continue another
iteration of our loop
let's pop the minimum from the frontier
this is gonna be the minimum three has
been popped
so let's add an edge connecting it to
our graph so so far this is what our
graph looks like since we popped 3 add
it to visit and let's add the cost
of it so 3 was the cost of adding node 3
so total our cost
is going to be seven so far so now three
has been visited now let's add the
frontier
of the neighbors of three of course one
and
zero have already been visited so we're
just focusing on two
and four we're going to add those to our
frontier they're already in our frontier
but yes we're going to be ending up
adding duplicates
to the frontier right so i'm not going
to you know actually focus too much on
the drawing but
there could be multiples of these in the
frontier and now
well which of these edges that are in
our front here or the nodes in our
frontier what's the minimum cost that we
could pop
i'm just gonna tell you that for the
cost of node four
it's going to be four and it's going to
be this right you can tell by the
picture that's pretty obvious
this is going to be the shortest way to
include the node 4.
so let's pop this node add it to
the edges list so 1 or 3
and 4 are going to be connected and the
cost of that one was
four so let's add four and let's add it
to the visit now
just so you know that let's say we did
end up popping the same node multiple
times because technically that's
possible right
we pop one four but we still have a four
remaining
in the frontier so we what if we popped
four again what would we do well we
would actually see that okay let's take
a look at our visit well four
is already been visited right so there's
no need to add this to visit again and
there's no need to add the frontier
of that again and there's no need to
take the cost of that
and add it to our total cost because
four was already connected to the graph
we don't wanna you know add a redundant
cost
okay but so now you can see that four
has been added to our graph
now what's the remaining neighbors of
four of course these three nodes have
already been visited so the only edge we
could possibly add that would be useful
would be
this to there but you can see that
that's a pretty long path right surely
we have a shorter path in our graph
to the two node so so you can see four
of them are already connected we just
need to connect one last one so let's
pop from our frontier again
this is gonna be obviously two is gonna
be the one that's popped but what
exactly is gonna be the cost of it
well i'll just tell you the cost is
gonna be nine and which edge is it gonna
be well by looking at the picture we'd
probably think one of these two is gonna
be connected to two either
like this or like this and i'll tell you
that the paths are actually not
of equal length if they were equal
length it wouldn't really matter what
which one we chose right
it would it would lead to the same cost
anyway but in this case i'll tell you
this is the shorter one
so and yes the cost of that is going to
be nine so we can pop this so we can say
okay
two has now been added two has been
visited now it wasn't
previously visited but now it's visited
and the cost of adding it was 9. so the
total cost
that we ended up getting was 20 20 was
the total cost
and now we know we're done because every
node in our graph has been connected you
can tell by the red
edges all of the nodes are connected we
added
four edges and we visited every single
of the five
nodes so the algorithm prim's algorithm
is just that simple i mean it's not
really simple until you've actually done
it a few times you've practiced it and
learned these concepts of
visit minheep and now we're actually
going to jump into the code it's about
20 to 30 lines
okay so let's write it out and like i
said so the first thing we're going to
be doing
is actually creating the adjacency list
because that's not given to us we're
just given a list of points so i'm going
to get the number of points we have
and then i'm going to start creating
that adjacency list so
and basically i'm going to refer to each
point in our list as
basically the index of that point so the
first point in our points list is going
to be point zero
the next one is going to be 0.1 etc etc
so we can just say for i in
range of the number of points we have so
for i in
range of n the number of points we're
basically going to take each point i
map it to a empty list so far now we're
actually going to build out that list so
for i in range of n
so for every single point we want to
compare it to every
other point in the graph so for j in
range i plus 1 all the way to n so we
don't want to compare each point to
itself
we just want to compare it to every
other point in the entire graph
and when we do that we want to get the
coordinates so
for the point at i we're just going to
get the x and y
coordinates so points at index i
and we're going to do the exact same
thing for the point at index
j inside of our loop we're going to get
each point
that we're comparing it to and then
we're just going to take
the distance the manhattan distance
between them and we can get that by
taking the absolute value of x1 minus x2
the absolute value of y1 minus y2
and so i'm going to just comment up
above that for each node work
we're mapping it to a list of points
and for each point we're basically going
to have the
cost and the node or the neighbor
each neighbor is going to be a pair
right so each edge is basically a
weighted edge don't forget about that
so we're going to say adjacency for i
append to it the cost or the distance
right and the node itself which is node
j and we're going to do the exact
opposite because technically these are
undirected edges they go both ways so
let's just do the exact opposite so
adjacency of j append to it the distance
same distance but instead we're
appending i because that's its neighbor
so this is how you build that adjacency
list and technically we could actually
not have to write this for loop out we
could actually you know
compute these calculations while we are
running prim's algorithm but the reason
i'm doing it before is just to
give a clear distinction this is the
edge portion this is like the extra
portion of this problem
the following part is literally just an
exact
implementation of prem's algorithm
nothing fancy
so let's define our variables we're
going to have a result which is of
course going to be the total cost
initially it's going to be 0. we're also
going to have a visit
set so it's going to tell us the the
points that have already been visited
we're also going to have a min heap
which is initially not going to be empty
we're going to be starting at point
zero and the cost of it is also going to
be zero so let me just put in a comment
that each pair is going to be the cost
and the point cost goes first the order
is important because that's what the min
heap is going to be minimizing it based
on
and so now we're actually going to do
the loop and remember we're going to
keep going while the length of visit is
less than the total number of points
which is n
and on each iteration we're going to be
popping from the min heap in python we
can say heap q
dot heap pop and from it we'll get a
pair of values
okay we have to specify which heap we're
popping from min heap
min h and we're going to get a pair of
values the we can call it cost
and the point let's call it i and
remember
we are adding duplicates to our min heap
so if we popped it this could have
already been visited so let's just check
if
i is in visit then we're just going to
skip this iteration of the loop we
don't want to have to process this same
node that's already been popped before
but if it hasn't been popped then we're
going to take the cost of it
add it to the result so we're adding
this fresh new
node that we haven't visited yet and
we're also going to add it to visit now
to make sure that it never gets visited
again
and then we're going to go through every
neighbor in its adjacency list
so the adjacency list of i and remember
each neighbor actually isn't just
one value it's going to be the cost so
let's call it neighbor
cost as well as the neighbor right up
above you remember that in our adjacency
list we added a pair of values in that
list cost and the node itself
so now for each neighbor so for nay if
the neighbor
is not in visit then we're going to be
adding it to our min heap
so then we can say heap q dot heap push
to the min heap we're going to be
pushing a pair of values remember we're
pushing the cost first so neighbor cost
and then the neighbor and that's it
right so we're just for every neighbor
all we're having to do is just add it to
the min heap right and then we're going
to go to the next iteration of the loop
repeat the exact same thing until we
visit every single node
once we've done that we know for sure
the result has the total cost
that it took so then at the end all we
have to do is return that
cost let me make sure i don't have a
space and yeah that's the exact thing so
you can see this is the portion that's
prim's algorithm everything else is just
some pre-work that we had to do yes we
could have taken this pre-work and mixed
it up into here but i just want to give
a clear
understanding to you all of what exactly
prim's algorithm entails this is just
stuff that's not necessarily related to
prim's algorithm
we do need an adjacency list though to
perform this algorithm efficiently
so i hope that this was helpful if it
was please like and subscribe it
supports the channel a lot and i'll
hopefully
see you pretty soon thanks for watching